stabilized
so
i'm very happy to
start the last session of the day which
is an exciting session about streaming
and
mostly about graph streaming
and we will see a combination of
interesting talks the
first one would be about a
boolean hidden matching which is a
useful lower bound technique
uh the second one
um
just remember the order so the second
one is about uh adversarial robust
streaming yeah those are the robust
coloring of
for graph streams
um
and
the last three are
exciting
exciting works about uh
so that the third one
obtains optimal bounds for dominating
set both for insertion only and for
insertion solutions the first one gets a
better
rounds space trade-off for
the feedback arcset problem in
tournaments and
the last one solves and resolves a long
line of research on
um
on
dynamic maximum matching in streams
so um
let me let us start with the first talk
and i'm happy to
invite
samsung
to talk
okay yeah um
so if i properly shared my screen you
should be able to see that the talk is
on um noisy bullying hidden matching in
applications
this work is by microcapilov
music
jacob tardos who prepared these
wonderful slides but couldn't speak
today due to the time difference
um dave woodruff and myself
um okay yeah so the bullion matching
problem is a one-way communication
problem that was first studied
independently by two different works in
2006
and in this problem there are two
players alice and bob
and alice receives a binary um vector of
length n
and these correspond to labels on n
vertices
and then bob receives a matching on
these um n vertices
it doesn't have to be complete matching
but it can be
and bob also receives an edge parity um
vector that we call w
and uh when we say an edge parity we say
that an edge has parity which is equal
to the sum of the labels of the vertices
for example the first edge on the right
which is labeled by zero
is equal to the sum of the two labels on
its endpoints which are both one
so in this problem bob must decide
whether the parity labels are all
correct which is the yes case are all
incorrect it's the no case
and in this example we have
the vector
of the edge parities being all correct
because the one corresponds to
sorry so the second edge corresponds to
two vertices that have parity one when
they are added together
and the bottom edge has parity zero so
all the labels are correct and this is
the yes case
so the bullying matching problem has
been used to solve um or to show lower
bounds for a number of graph problems in
the streaming model
um i see that uh you know a bunch of
authors of these previous works are
attendants but you know just to blame
the point it's been used to show lower
bounds and triangle counting maximum
matching
max cut and maximum cyclic subgraph to
name a few
but one weakness of this
communication protocol is that it's
known that bullying and matching
requires root n bits of communication
and so this often translates to getting
lower bounds of root n
and this may not be the most
satisfactory because a lot of these
problems seem to be a lot harder
and indeed if you consider the
generalization to boolean hidden hyper
matching
where
each edge is now a hyper edge of size t
and bob needs to define the parities on
these hyperedges as either all being
correct or all being incorrect
then we can show that the boolean hidden
hypermatching problem requires space
sorry communication n to the one minus
one over t
so this boolean hidden hyper matching
problem has been used to show stronger
lower bounds in these problems that i um
listed before
so we'll go over one quick illustration
of lower bound reduction actually it's
not even going to be
an example i'll just briefly describe
some bits of the gadget
so in the streaming lower bound
for max cut by kapralov khan and sudan
they reduced the problem to bhh which is
bullying hyper matching using the
following gadget
so alice gets a number of vertices and
vertices to be exact and alice encodes
each bit into four vertices
so we won't go with the rest of the
details
but the point is that after the
reduction is done if the label of the
edge paradise is correct then there is
no odd cycle
and if the label is incorrect then there
is an odd cycle
and in both cases these cycles will have
length roughly t
so this is the case where w equals zero
so this is the correct case and this is
the incorrect case but you can see that
the red line in both these cases
has induces a cycle that is uh quite
long
so capital of khan and sudan show that a
one plus epsilon approximation to max
cut requires one n to the one minus
epsilon space roughly
but again you know these cycles have
length one over epsilon roughly speaking
so these graphs can have a large
diameter
so natural question is whether these
hardness results still apply if the
diameter of the graph is quite small
so this motivated us to study the noisy
billion hand matching problem
where
the yes case still corresponds to
edge parity vectors that are all correct
but in the no case
only a small probability of
flipping the edge labels
will induce a small number of incorrect
edge labels so recall that in the
boolean matching case
all the edge labels are either all right
or all wrong
but in noisy boolean and matching
they're either all right or a small
number of them are wrong
and we observe that this is a
distributional communication problem
and that we can similarly define a noisy
bullying hidden hypermatching problem
so intuitively this should be a harder
problem
and indeed i'll describe this uh plain
text protocol that does show it can be
harder so consider the protocol where
alice just sends s bits of the labels of
the vertices
now if bob detects an incorrect edge
label then he can answer no or otherwise
he answers yes
and the probability that the edge parity
is known to bob is roughly s squared
over n this can be shown by saying that
the probability that bob knows a single
vertex
label is s over n so you know the
probability that bob knows both is s
squared over n squared and then there
are n edges so you do union bound it's
like roughly a squared over n
um
but now for us the probability that b
knows an edge parity and the
corresponding label is noisy is going to
be roughly p times s squared over n
so in this case we see that space s
equals root n over p suffices and we'll
call that p smaller than one so this is
going to use more space in root n
similarly we can show some
a similar protocol for noisy bullying
hidden hyper matching
and turns out that this protocol is
essentially tight
namely we can show a randomized one-way
protocol that succeeds with constant
probability for this communication
problem requires root and over p bits of
communication
and using this lower bound we can get
lower bounds for
uh one pass string algorithms for max
cut max matching
um and maximum sqlite subgraph
and these lower bounds have
sorry the lower bound is
root n over p
but the caveat is that these graphs in
these constructions can now have small
diameter namely they can have constant
diameter
before i talk about the analysis i just
like to mention the previous approach
which uses for approaches to bound the
l2 squared distance between the
posterior distributions of the edge
labels in the yes and no cases
now we can try to mimic this approach
using the uh the p noisy operator
but it turns out that the uh l2 square
distance is quite loose
and we can't actually show a good
difference between the posterior
distributions
so the natural approach using fourier
analytic techniques doesn't quite work
at least uh we don't we don't know how
to show it works
so instead we use an information
theoretical approach and we reformulate
noisy bhm as multiple instances of
blending hidden matching then we create
roughly one of our p instances a boolean
hand matching
and each of these instances are going to
have random size so they're going to
have some size that's uh drawn from the
binomial distribution with n events and
probability p
and now in the no case we'll define a
single instance of bhm so one of these
one over p instances is going to be no
and the rest are still yes
and in the s case all these instances
are going to be yes
so intuitively it means that we need to
solve all these bhm instances um
independently and correctly
so we can do this using the complexity
of a protocol based on internal
information cost
and it's been previously shown
um while communication complexity of
ruling and matching has been shown but
one can use that to show that the
information cost of billionaire matching
is roughly root n
now the idea is that we have one of our
p instances
each of these instances will be of size
roughly n times p due to the
randomized instance
and so if we multiply these together you
know we'll have a root np communication
for each information cost for each of
these instances they're one over p
instances so that gives the lower bound
of root n over p
and now we can use a similar
construction to capital of canaan's
sudan to show that
we can get one plus epsilon
approximation lower bounds that have
roughly in space
for small diameter gadgets so this
problem max cut is still hard even if
the graph has small diameter
similarly you can get lower bounds for
max matching and maximum cyclic subgraph
so in summary we introduced the problem
a p noisy blade in matching and we show
that it requires space communication
root n over p
and then the natural generalization when
hyper matching requires space uh sorry
communication n to the one minus one
over t
um divided by t p to the one over t
we use additive internal information
costs to show this lower bound and we
get new
streaming lower balance for these graph
problems even when the diameter has
small size
and that's it thanks
thank you very much samsung um so the
model is we we only have 10 minutes per
talk and there's not not a lot of time
for
questions so there's one there's time
for one quick question per talk maybe
and then 10 minutes at the end of the
hour
so is there any question
okay if not let's say thank uh samsung
again
and um
our next speaker
will be manuel stockhole
and he will talk about adversarial
robust coloring in graph streams
okay now i'm going to read it you can
hear me right yep
so i'm talk my name is daniel stuckle
i'm going to present um slides for paper
on address failure plus calling graph
streams um this is a joint work with
amit chaka bharti and franz argosh
with overview i'm going to explain what
problem we're looking at the results we
have give if time permits simplified
overviews of the proofs and algorithms
and then mention a few open problems
that are interested in
um so what is adversarial streaming it's
a setting that's been introduced in the
last um
or in two years i want to think of it
you have a two-player game between an
adversary who provides stream of
elements and an algorithm whose goal is
to um
at any point in that stream of elements
produce an output depending on what has
been seen so far
as with all streaming algorithms you
have you're allowed the algorithm is
allowed limited space to remember what
the stream inputs are
we say that an algorithm is
adversarially robust if they if the
algorithm um
produces outputs that have a low error
probability of their task for any given
adapt for any given adaptive adversary
by negative adversary i mean one which
following the game can look at um
previous outputs of the algorithm and
try and use those to construct an input
to which the algorithm is more likely to
fail
in this framework the standard assuming
model is the cadmium oblivious adversary
that never looks at the outputs of the
algorithm as also has mentioned that
deterministic algorithms are
automatically adversely robust because
in deterministic adversary in
deterministic algorithm you're never
allowed any error
okay so the problem we're looking at in
particular is streaming graph coloring
we're given a sequence of edges of some
and vertex graph
we're not allowed any repetitions in the
edges
and the edges form a graph whose maximum
degree is delta
the goal of the algorithm is to output
at each point in the stream a k color in
the graph where k is some parameter
which is at least delta plus one
in the standard streaming setting the
server paper already solves this it's by
a starting contact 2019 and they give an
oblivious delta plus one coloring
algorithm which uses roughly ends which
uses roughly n bits of space
however like
um
all existing calling algorithms adaptive
address series can break it the question
we're looking at in this
paper and talk is whether there exist
robust streaming algorithms which
require is whether robust streaming
algorithms require significantly more
space to solve this problem
so we find that the answer is yes in
particular if we have any adversarial
bust k coloring
streaming algorithm that needs at least
n delta squared over k bits of space
where delta is the
maximum graph degree as a consequence if
we want to delta plus one color or o
delta color graph we're going to need
um omega n omega n delta bits of space
similarly for that only semi streaming
space so and space then we need at least
delta squared colors
there's also a it's worth i should
mention a
work independent to ours which finds
that if you're allowed o and space then
a deterministic algorithm needs to use
even more than delta squared colors they
need to use some quantity which is
exponential in delta in fact
we also find um
let's see
sorry we also find adversarial robust
algorithms which can delta squared color
an edge insertion stream
and which um
which can build this chord called
insertion stream using roughly o and
delta o n squared delta space
this algorithm has a few variations
which work for
um
graph streams where you're allowed to
delete edges that you insert in the past
i also provided delta cube coloring
algorithm that uses semi-streaming space
but with the trade-off of
needing access to a large pool of random
bits
so
the core of our
lower bound is to reduce to a
communication problem which we call
subset of points problem this is
parameters t and b the idea is that you
have two players alice um when the
players knows the subset u of
size a wants to send a message to bob
bob on the other hand wants to use that
message to
discover a given um
let's use the message to discover a set
v of size b which is entirely different
from you you can solve this problem by
um
you can solve this problem by sending a
um set consultation form by sending the
set you entirely but that's can be
fairly inefficient a more efficient
approach for this is to
send is to picker is to pick a random
for ls to pick a random set of v and
send the only the intersection of u and
v
um
we
prove that this problem require for this
problem needs at least omega a b over t
of its communication to solve
with um constant error
so how do we link this to the graph
calling problem
um
it turns out that if we're given an
adversarial adverse earlier bust sketch
for graph coloring we can find many it's
possible to find many um edges that are
not in the graph
encoded by the sketch specifically if
you take the given given a sketch given
a sketch for a graph you can find the um
if that's for the graph you can produce
the coloring of the graph
and then um
then you can find non-edged and they can
find many non-edges since between every
pair of edges with the same color since
between any since between every pair of
vertices that have the same color in
your coloring there cannot be a graph
there cannot be an edge in the original
graph
furthermore because the sketch is
adversarially robust um we can it's
because it's adversarial bust it is
possible to use some of the non-edges
that were revealed by the coloring take
those edges take those non-edges add um
add them into the
add them back into the sketch so you
have to add them back into the sketch to
compute the coloring of your
um
compute the coloring of your updated
graph and that coloring is going to
reveal even more edges which are not in
your original
graph
so because of this the sketch is
very similar to avoid in fact you can
use
this graph calling sketch as part of
protocol which solves
multiple copies of the void the exact
details of um
the way both exactly because of how
we're you um
selling multiple copies or finicky you
could you can see them in the full
version of the paper
and then
now that we have the reduction on the
lower bound on the message size for a
void can show implies the desired lower
bound of the size of sketches
for graph coloring
okay
um
looks like
i'll need to speed up to keep this
talking bounds um
so to briefly describe one of the upper
bound algorithms um for a delta squared
algorithm we're using a variation on
existing technique under sketch
switching where different times we are
using uh
sketch switching where the algorithm
stores multiple copies of existing
sketch and at different times it
switches between which sketch it is
using to
compute its output output from
um
this algorithm we're using
this algorithm we also maintain a buffer
of recent edges
and by using that buffer we can delay
how by using that buffer we can delay
how often we need to switch between
the
underlying sketches for our coloring the
trade-off is i think the trade-off is
that we end up using more colors than
um
a few more colors than in the obvious
case
we also present a delta cube coloring
algorithm
the
again i can only give a short
description um
but this is modifying the core of
some existing streaming graphically
algorithms um these algorithms typically
these algorithms typically assign a
random palette
of colors for every single vertex
and use
of colors every single vertex and then
only store
edges and only end up storing edges for
which conflicts between
um
only store end up storing edges for
which pellets between different vertices
overlap and then you and then when you
color
vertices
um using color and palettes you um
only need to check those two i just that
you stored
um
yeah
let's see the matrix here is that you
still the metric here is that you use a
different set of colors
sorry the metric here is that for every
single degree of a vertex you use a
different subset of colors and that
makes it possible to
prevent the adversary from
predicting what predicting what palettes
are going to be used when you're
printing what palettes are going to be
used for a
vertex
when you um
after you add an edge to it
okay
so conclusions we prove a lower bound on
um we prove a lower improvement omega
and delta squared over k lower bound for
robust algorithms
um space lower bound for best algorithms
decay color an edge insertion stream
with maximum degree delta we also
present to also
present a few um
robust coloring out also present a few
robust coloring algorithms
open problems we found interesting one
of the main ones is whether or not the
lower boundary proven is tight for
example with some streaming space the
lower bound we have predicts that you
need at least delta squared colors
however the best that we proved as of
time of writing was oh delta cube colors
we've since improved that slightly but
but there still is a gap
we're also interested in knowing whether
there exists robust coloring algorithms
for long for very long streams that have
many engines or some deletions
and like
much of the rest of the field we'd like
to find an oblivious
we like to find a space separation
between oblivious
and adversarial models for natural
estimation problems like the example of
approximating
um second moment of our turn cell
streams that's been studied a few times
over the last few years over the last
few years
okay thank you for listening
thank you very much
um so i think our time is up for
questions on this one but again there
are there's time for question in the end
of the hour so please please stay if you
have uh
questions then
um
and and then thanks thanks manuel again
uh our next talk uh will be by christian
conrad about the optimal bounds for
streaming dominating set
all right all right good i hope you can
see the screen um
all right so um this is about uh
dominating set in graph streams it's a
joint work with sanjeev khanna from
university of pennsylvania
um so we talk about so this work is
about the data streaming setting and um
so the streaming setting is sort of
characterized by this typical sequential
access
now uh we look at graph problems so in
graph problems we have two main models
that we work with there's the insertion
only model where essentially edges
arrive one by one in arbitrary order and
we look at an insertion deletion model
where edges arrive but can also be
deleted again afterwards from the stream
and
in both settings uh space
little of n square would be what we
would be aiming for
because this would essentially be
already a non-trivial bound for very
dense graphs
now um
so this work is about dominating sets so
here's our an example we've got an input
graph g then let's first look at what a
dominating set is a dominating set is a
subset of vertices
um such that the inclusive neighborhood
of this subset
is the entire input graph so all the
vertices so in other words for every
vertex that's not included in the
dominating set there must be a vertex in
the dominating set in its neighborhood
a minimum dominating set is one simply
then of smallest size and
we're interested in approximation
algorithms so
a dominating set is an alpha
approximation if its size is at most
alpha times the optimal size
so the approximation factors here are
larger than one
now um
the dominating set problem as such has
not been uh studied in the data
streaming setting so far but a related
problem the set cover problem has been
studied quite extensively in the data
streaming setting so um let's
talk therefore first a bit about set
cover so
in set cover um the setting is quite
similar but different so the input is
that we have a universe of size n
then we've got a set family of sets so
overall we've got m sets and these are
all subsets of our universe
the output should be
a smallest subset possible of these sets
that cover the entire universe so we
need to find a small subset
again that covers essentially the
inter-universe
now
we all know that these two problems you
can reduce them to each other in linear
time but it turns out in the data
streaming setting they are somewhat
different and but before we talk about
this sort of this difference
um so there's a important connection in
this direction in that if we had a
dominating set instance and like this
one we have some input graph g
um to obtain a set cover instance we can
just see that if we set the universe to
be the set of vertices of our input
graph and the set family would then
consist of the inclusive neighborhoods
of the vertices that we've got
so we would have essentially an instance
on n sets and the universe also size n
here
so to
when if we want to solve dominating set
using
a set cover algorithm for example
now i'm going to the streaming streaming
model um so set cover has been studied
quite extensively in the streaming
setting and the model that is considered
is typically here a set arrival setting
so that is um the arrival order is we
see the sets of the input one by one in
arbitrary order so we have some sequence
of the sets but then uh what does that
mean the sequence of the sets it means
that you learn about the identifier of
the set and as well about the elements
that are contained in the set so in
other words
whenever a set arrives you know exactly
what the set looks like
um
right so this is the um perhaps best
described as a set arrival setting
and um the following results are known
in a one pass setting in the streaming
setting so um interestingly for an
approximation factor of root n roughly
we can get a semi-streaming algorithm
with space basically o tilde of n
now if we want an approximation factor
that's better than root n
for uh approximation factor little over
root n then suddenly the space kind of
explodes and you need space n times m
over alpha
so there's a bit there's some some phase
transition going on at this
approximation trade of root n for
anything better than root n suddenly the
space is n times m over alpha but for
root n um space n is enough
good
so um so we know pretty well what is
happening for for set cover in the set
arrival setting in the streaming setting
now if we go to a dominating set now
then um it's of course much more natural
to consider an edge arrival model
because ultimately dominating set is a
graph problem and we say edges arriving
one by one
so if we see edges arriving one by one
then we we still can connect sort of
this setting to a set cover setting and
for example if the h45 arrives to
connects vertex 4 to
um then we could uh sort of on the fly
construct a set cover um instance um
indicating sort of an edge arrival set
cover setting indicating that the set
number four contains the item number
five and the set number five at the same
time contains the item number four so we
can sort of um relate these problems
still together
to each other however we don't have any
more the property that entire sets
arrive we'd rather have an edge arrival
setting where sort of a set arrives with
sort of one element that belongs to it
and
ultimately it means that over the course
of processing the stream the elements
that are contained in a sector might
appear at arbitrary moments in the
stream and that will be ultimately
ultimately the difficulty that we have
to deal with
so in a sense a streaming dominating set
can be sort of compared to an edge
arrival set cover setting where we have
um essentially n sets
so um
now
the results that are known for set cover
in the set arrival setting and
interestingly there's uh um
there are two results that apply as well
for the edge arrival setting and will
also translate to dominating set
and um
let's see that's uh in fact this result
here so
as long as we if we want an
approximation factor better than root n
then uh
um the upper bound and the lower bound
of this result uh they translate to
dominating set that is
space essentially n square because we
have n sets now for dominating set n
square over alpha
um is best possible for approximation
factors uh little of root n
so this even holds in insertion deletion
streams so the the setting is
essentially already ruled out um by by
this result here
um but still um there are some open
questions of course then the main
question is what happens at exactly this
threshold root n where we see this phase
transition for set cover so it is not
clear um that the algorithm for sort of
set arrival set cover would translate to
a natural rival setting so the question
is is there as well a phase transition
here or not
and um yeah the question is as well what
happens in the insertion deletion
setting if our approximation factor is
not little over then it's uh in this and
omega from n
so the results that we get um are as
follows so first we have an algorithm
for the insertion
only setting
and indeed there it turns out um similar
to the set arrival setting there's as
well a one pass algorithm for dominating
set with an approximation factor of
roughly root n and semi streaming space
so um
this algorithm can also be applied to
arbitrary set cover instances that have
this edge arrival um
in the edge arrival setting
and yeah we see in fact exactly the same
phase transition here as well
now um
there's not enough time really to go
into the algorithm but as an intuition
um
the way the reason the set arrival
situation works so well is because
entire sets arrive one by one and you
can essentially with each arriving set
decide whether this set should be
included in the solution you can do that
if the set covers enough
enough new vertices in the input graph
so that's sort of the big advantage now
we can't do this here anymore so instead
um uh what what we do in terms of
strategy is to say uh well ideally we
want to include only uh vertices in the
solution and dominating set if they have
a large enough degree
so we'll just let the first root and
edges go that means the sort of vertex
accumulated a decent amount a decent
degree and only then we attempt to
insert this vertex when it has
accumulated root and degree into our
solution but of course we can't do this
for all the vertices so we essentially
downsample we include with a probability
of one over root n here
and uh we carry on in such a way and
this inclusion probability would be
exponentially increased uh step by step
and
this indeed
effectively works to not take too many
vertices but you still take the vertices
of large degree and you end up with a
similar approximation factor
then um we have a lower bound as well
for the insertion deletion setting so um
this lower bound says that this
situation in insertion deletion streams
is in fact quite simple
so um for an alpha approximation there's
a lower bound of n square over alpha in
the insertion deletion setting and now
this holds for any value of alpha so um
uh the there's a matching upper bound
that translates from the set cover
setting so the setting is
essentially ruled out now this lower
bound is an information complexity level
bound with a direct sum argument
using
a set intersection problem that was
defined in
the paper cited down here
so as a summary essentially um we have
optimal bounds for dominating sets both
in the insertion only and in this in the
insertion deletion setting for
essentially the whole range of
parameters approximation parameters
sulfur
again the
upper bound extends to general set cover
instances with space m plus n if you
have m sets in a universe of size n
and
a follow-up work recently we could prove
that this space is essentially also
optimal in the actual rival settings so
we need this dependency on m and n as
well
for an approximation
there's maybe one open question here and
that's that essentially
almost all set cup and dominating set
now space low bounce that within
streaming they require that algorithms
produce a cover certificate sort of
indicating a specific vertex is covered
by you know this vertex and the solution
and they really strongly rely on this
assumption and the question is really
whether we can avoid this
right um then yeah thanks very much for
listening
thank you christian
um again we're a bit over time so we'll
keep the questions for the
for the end of the hour
but
thanks christian and um
we will
move to our fourth
talk of the session
about
semi-streaming feedback arcset
um
and
yeah here's ano so i'm happy to have
uh anubhav
from
uh cmu i'm audible
wait uh sounds good uh hi my name is
anubhav and today i'll be presenting an
efficient semi streaming pdas for the
tournament feedback outside problem done
in few passes
this was done in collaboration with
justin gia and david woodruff at cmu
um
so
we'll start off by first defining the
permutation
the cost of a permutation pi uh on a
vertex set v and a weight matrix w where
the weight matrix w can be
thought of as the adjacency matrix
on
a vertex at v
and it is essentially
uh the number of
back edges that are going uh that are
present in that particular permutation
uh
and the goal
of the feedback arcser problem is to
find such a permutation pi star which
minimizes the total cost which minimizes
the total number of packages in that
permutation for any permutation and
on tournament graphs uh
this problem is much more
easier to manage because
uh even though on general graphs this
problem is np hard and it was shown by
alone that even on tournament graphs
this problem is np hard
uh there does exist like uh that already
does exist a pitas for this uh problem
on tournament uh graphs and therefore
our goal is to produce a streaming
algorithm which achieves the same
approximation factor
um so there are like several motivations
and applications for
uh the tournament feedback oxide problem
the most prominent one being kim any
young rank aggregation uh
in which we can kind of rephrase the
true memory back oxide problem to be
thought of as a
ranking by pairwise comparison problem
where we are given a list of items and
we are given pair wise preferences
between all between all pairs of items
and we want to find an ordering of the
items which has like the least amount of
disagreements and
this has like a various application in
search engine results and machine
translations
um
previous work on this problem
is vast um so
i guess the most straightforward thing
uh
is that sorting by winds which is just
like sorting
the vertices by their in degree already
gives us like a five approximation
factor and this algorithm is polynomial
in and only requires one pass and
requires like only n log and space um
and uh in this in through this
presentation we will be using this o
star notation which basically means that
we'll be hiding there which hides away
polylogging over epsilon factors
uh recently in a
soda paper
uh by chakrabarty at all
they presented a couple of algorithms uh
including the modified k wick sort which
can achieve a three approximation factor
and can uh also achieve this like a very
nice trade-off between passes and space
of like p passes versus o star of n to
the one plus one over p space
uh pitas as we mentioned earlier does
exist
the chuckleberry paper also presented a
oneplus approximate epsilon
approximation factor algorithm which has
a one pass and o star of n space so it
seems like the ideal solution but
unfortunately it uses exponent
exponential and n time
and then finally uh our result
which achieves a one plus epsilon
approximation factor uh in a polynomial
time with p passes and the like o star
of n plus one over one n plus n to the
one plus one over p space as was similar
to the trade-off that the chuckleworthy
paper achieved
um
yeah so as we mentioned earlier that
this is our result and this is what we
will be uh striving towards in this
presentation
uh so in order to first
present the algorithm we first need to
understand this idea of a single vertex
move which is essentially a local
optimization method which uh
was used
in the query efficient setting by alon
and also in the p task uh presented by
kenyan shudi
and
the idea behind a single vertex move is
all you do is you take a vertex and you
move it to a certain uh different
position in the permutation such that
the overall cost of the permutation
decreases and you get a better
communication the idea of
several of these algorithms is to apply
repeatedly cost improving single vertex
modes to
somehow reach a like a like a local
optimum and uh show that that local
optimum in fact like uh does uh
give us a one plus epsilon approximation
of the
uh minimum feedback part set on the
tournament graph
so the key insights of our algorithm in
order to actually emulate it in a
streaming setting are that we first want
to
approximate the cost improvement
achieved by the single vertex moves
using sampling we can't store the entire
graph we can't store
everything um
because we are
trying to achieve subquadratic space and
therefore we cannot
always have access to
how much cost improvement we will
achieve by making a single vertex move
and therefore that has to be done with
sampling
another key insight is that we want to
have multiple copies of these sample
sets because
once we use a sample set to
make a single vertex move we now have a
new uh permutation and in some way we
want a fresh sample set that
is still independent of the permutation
and still has all the property all the
desirable properties that we needed to
have
um
a third and key
insight we had was that we only need to
make strong single vertex moves which
essentially means that we only need to
make moves which are long
by long i mean they have they are linear
in length with respect to the sub
problem and they also achieve a
significant cost improvement which means
that they have
a
polylog in our epsilon factors a linear
amount of cost improvement
as compared to the length of the move
itself and therefore the actual size of
the sub problem
uh another insight
that we made was that if that we can
make multiple single vertex moves in
parallel such that the realized cost
improvement is still good so if we have
a set of
cost improving single vertex moves which
have their own cost improvement
uh we can actually make them at the same
time um
and approximate their costs using like
the same sample sets um
and without in such a way that the total
cost improvement that we would have
anticipated from making all of these uh
single vertex moves individually is
approximately the same as the realized
cost improvement when we made all of
them in parallel
um so
we start with the algorithm overview uh
we first obtain a five approximation by
sorting by uh in degree uh using uh the
copper smith result
um
and then we recursively first of all if
the input is small enough we could force
it if the cost is high enough we want to
use like an add approximation algorithm
that was given by freeze at all and we
show that that algorithm can also be
simulated in our semi streaming setting
um
but otherwise we want to call this
approx local improve method which is the
key
local optimization method which actually
makes the single vertex moves on each
sub problem in this recursive algorithm
and then finally once we make those
local optimizations through
approx local improve we divide the sub
we divide the problem into two sub
problems and then further recurse down
the tree
uh now this is the meat of the algorithm
prox vocal improve the local
optimization algorithm uh
the sample sets of evi are used to
approximate the cost improvement of the
single vertex moves and then uh
this method essentially executes strong
single vertex moves in parallel uh until
like no single no strong single vertex
move actually remains on that particular
permutation
uh so in order to
get a high level idea of why this
algorithm works um
we need to break down the cost of a
permutation
into two parts uh according to our
algorithm um so one is like uh can be
considered alpha x which is the total uh
which where x is a leaf in the recursion
tree and alpha x is the
cost incurred by that particular leaf
whereas beta x is the cost incurred at
the internal nodes of the recursion tree
um and
the total cost of this particular
mutation is just the sum of all the
alpha x and all the beta x's
and this is an important lemma
that uh
we
got from a lawn in his query deficient
efficient
setting work where he shows that
uh
the expected value of the
total sum of all the cost at the
internal nodes
as a as well
as well as the
optimal cost at the leaves
is at most one plus epsilon times the
optimal cost on the entire permutation
um so this is like a very uh
important for us because uh ultimately
at the leaves we always end up uh
either brute forcing or calling the add
approximation algorithm and therefore
we do achieve a very close to the
optimal
solution i believe and therefore all we
need to do is we want to achieve
we want to show that we make every
single single a strong single vertex
move that alarms algorithm makes that we
are making as well in order to actually
be able to use this level
uh our time is officially up so we maybe
take one or two minutes to wrap up okay
yeah i'm almost done okay sorry um
so
uh given all these suppositions and the
fact that we're only making strong
single vertex moves we show that
uh the total uh
uh that because every single strong
strong single vertex moves has a costume
linear in n and the maximum cost of the
feedback arc set can be like theta n
squared the number of times new strong
single vertex moves will be created by
making these strong single vertex moves
is very small and therefore the number
of sample sets that we need to store and
therefore the number of passes we need
to make is also very small and
therefore uh we are able to get away
with doing it executing this algorithm
in the semi streaming setting
we can also see that the proxy improve
uh method only requires one pass so the
entire algorithm only requires log and
password high probability one for each
other recursion tree
and finally we can partition different
layers of the recursion tree based on
the sizes of the subproblem
to achieve a trade-off in p passes and
o star of n to the one plus one over p
space
and finally other than the feedback arc
set result uh we also achieve
a few minor results such as a
deterministic algorithm for finding
strongly connected components in
tournament graphs and a single pass some
single pass lower bounds for some
director graph problems and also some
multiple pass lower bounds for
strong connectivity uh in a few passes
um
and uh that is it thank you
thank you very much and love
um
so uh
we'll go straight to the last talk of
this session by v hancha from ratgers
hi so can you see my screen
yes
okay i'm the cursor as well right
okay
so um yeah hey everyone
uh so today i'll be talking about an
asymptotically optimal algorithm for
maximum matching and dynamic streams
this is joint work with separatisation
at rutgers university
so
what is the matching problem right so
given a graph and a matching is just a
bunch of edges that don't share any
endpoints and the maximum matching is
the matching of the largest size so here
you can see a matching and here
m starts the maximum matching of this
graph
the setting we're interested in is
streaming
and in this setting the information
comes bit by bit in a stream you observe
the current bit and update the memory
and once this bit goes ahead you don't
have access to it anymore
so in terms of graphs the edges of the
graph will appear in a stream and the
vertices are fixed from 1 to n
and since we're looking at dynamic
streams the edges can be inserted or
deleted
so let's look at a quick example
and edges are being inserted in this
graph
and this red edge here shows an edge
deletion and this is the final graph
so in this setting we want to output a
solution at the end of the stream so
it's important to note that you don't
have to maintain one throughout
and the goal is to minimize the amount
of memory used
unfortunately there's a lower bound here
so you need n square bits for this
problem and also you can triple store
the whole input and n square bits
so there's no non-trivial solution and
when such things happen you usually look
for approximations so the question is
what about an alpha approximation
you want to return a matching m with
size at least m star over alpha where m
star is the maximum matching
can we get the flow of n square space
so what is the
trade-off between alpha and the space
so previous work uh tries and answers
this problem conduct 15 gave an upper
bound of n square over alpha square and
a lower bound of n 1.5 or alpha 4. asadi
at all gave
an upper bound of n square over alpha
cube this tilde over here is hiding
polylog factors
and a lower bound of roughly n squared
over alpha cube
titan set i'll give the same bound and
then dark conda 20 give a lower bound of
n square over alpha cube bits
and now you see that the gap between the
best known upper bound and lower bound
is polyorgan bits right so this is the
best one upper bound on the lower bound
and these polylog n gaps occur very
frequently in dynamic streaming
literature and usually the reason is
this main technique for finding edges
which is l0 sampling
so the problem is
in a dynamic stream
you want to find just one edge of the
graph
and that itself is a non-trivial problem
because what if you find an edge and
that's related later
so l0 samples are a key tool to solve
this problem
and they can basically sample edges
uniformly at random from sets of pairs
of vertices that undergo edge insertions
and deletions
they can be implemented in log cube and
bits of space but they also need log
equivalent to space
and many uh problems they have this poly
log overhead because of l0 samplers
connectivity uh for example has this
lower bound of n log cube n by nelson
u19
so we raise the question is this polylog
always necessary right
so now we show our result
so we prove asymptotically optimal
bounds on the space approximation
trade-off
so we give a dynamic streaming algorithm
that with high probability gives you an
alpha approximation
and it uses n square over alpha cube
bits of space
so this closes the gap up to constant
factors right because dark online had a
lower bound of n square over here cube
and we also answered the question that
we raised in the previous slide that we
always don't need this this boy log
overhead so we don't have it here
and you might be wondering why alpha
less than n to the one half it's because
for greater alpha there's not enough
space to output the answer so n over
alpha is greater than our space bound
okay so now we'll show how we prove
these results starting with a few
assumptions
so uh the input graph is bipartite the
maximum matching has a large size of
omega n
and getting a theta alpha approximation
is enough
and it's important to note that all of
these assumptions can be lifted
so what is the approach we use
so there are two steps the first one is
called match or sparsify
so it it either gives you a large
matching or it identifies a hard
instance
and the second step is to solve this
hard instance
and now we run both of these algorithms
in parallel it's important to note that
okay so let's look at match or sparsify
um over here we either get a large
matching which is of size n over alpha
so this uh is the matching uh and we
call it mz
and also it's important to note that we
run an n square over alpha qubits right
good
so we either find this large matching
and we're done
if this matching we find does not have a
large size so this thing over here if it
has size less than n over alpha then if
you look at the sub graph induced on the
unmatched vertices this green portion
here
it has only o tilde and edges and it
also has a very large matching
so
ah this is our hard instance right
the idea for match or sparsify is
basically you sample n square over alpha
cube polylog and random edges this
polylogin is in the denominator and you
do the sampling using l0 samplers so you
see that the space will be n square
alpha cube bits
and then out of all the sample edges m e
z is just a greedy matching over all the
sampled edges
and then we come up with a property that
is similar to the residual property of
greedy matching
and uh
and it's different enough but it's along
the same lines
so
now we're left with uh this hard
instance right so this is what we have
to solve
and mattress partify gives us this
partition at the end of the stream so
it's important to note it's at the end
in particular you get this matching m e
z right
and this will be important will be
important for us to remember what i'm
easy is so i'll just keep this diagram
on the bottom here
so this is our input graph the first
step is to partition the vertices you
partition it randomly into groups of
size alpha
now if you look at one group what you do
is you look at all the groups on the
right and you sample one over alpha
fraction of the groups and you call it
its neighborhood
and this is done to reduce the number of
neighbors of v i
so now
there are n over alpha omega n over
alpha pairs of groups with exactly one
edge between them we can prove such a
thing right so the picture kind of looks
like this so there's v i v j and there
is exactly one edge between them
and v i and v j they do not contain any
vertices of m and z right so they don't
contain any vertices from here
so now if we're able to recover all such
edges we get a matching of size n over
alpha omega n over alpha and we're done
okay so our goal will be now to recover
all such edges
uh between v and v j
so now if you look at v i it completely
lies within this green portion here
right
because it does not contain vertices of
m
and now the number of neighbors of v i
are n over alpha square right because
most of its neighbors here and we did a
sub sampling of one over alpha so this
becomes an over alpha squared
so how do we get this edge
we can trivially just store all the
edges of v i right that'll give us n
over alpha square times log n with
subspace
okay that's easy but we don't want this
log n factor here
we want n over alpha square bits
and it's important
to see why because n over r for groups
will then imply a space of
n square over alpha cube the log n
factor would have messed up our space
bound
so now if you see that v j also does not
contain any vertices of m e z so v j
also lies within here
so now you can just recover n of v i
minus m e you don't have to recover all
of nfpr
and this is exactly what our sketch does
so we come up with a sketch called
sparse neighborhood recovery
what does it do so given vi at the
beginning of the stream
and you're given me z this matching at
the end of the stream
sorry
and um you want to recover n of v i
minus m e z this moon shaped region here
so our sketch does it in n over alpha
square bits
and now you can see
that um
all the neighbors of v i that are within
v j they lie within this region here
right because v j does not contain any
vertices from here
so now we're able to get this end point
of vj
but we haven't recovered the edge
completely yet we know this end point
but we don't know this one
okay so what do we do for that
we store neighborhood sketches for both
vi and vj so now if you look at the
neighborhood sketchup vi it will tell
you oh there is this vertex u within v j
which is its neighbor and now you look
at the enabled sketch of v j it'll tell
you that o within v i there is this
vertex v which is its neighbor and now
since
you get both of these conditions you you
know that uv is the edge you're looking
for
and you've recovered that edge
and thus you're done right you can
recover a matching of size omega number
now we conclude
so we give a dynamic streaming algorithm
that with high probability gives you an
alpha approximation and it takes n
square of alpha cube bits of space
at the lower bound of dark count at 20
is n square over alpha cube bits and
this makes our algorithm optimal
and these polylog overheads are not
always necessary like in our case right
but these polylog and overheads are very
frequent
so the question we raise is can our
techniques be used to bypass this
polylog and these spylogan overheads and
some problems to think about is like
vertex cover dominating set vertex
connectivity
so this is all i have and thank you so
much for listening
thank you vihan for the very nice talk
and thank you to all of the speakers
that this is uh
these are very
nice and impressive results that we've
seen in the last hour
um and i think now we can have some time
for uh questions so you can ask
questions to any of the authors or
any any of the other earth speakers or
any subset of the speakers
and since we are the last session so
we have we are free to go over time i
guess so
uh so
uh if anyone has so uh
uh since the attendees that are not
panelists technically cannot
cannot cannot show themselves and ask
questions so you can
either write in the chat or in the qa or
that you would want to ask a question or
just to ask the question in the qa
in the q a
so let me maybe start with a
question to manuel if you are here
yes
um
so
maybe the uh
uh it might relate to something that you
said in your talk but
uh
uh so your result uh
with the
delta cubed the the upper bound with the
delta cube the
uh colors
uh as far as i remember it it uses uh
sketch switching which is kind of a
primitive technique in in in adversarial
robust streaming and i wonder whether
maybe differential privacy related
techniques can can do better or what or
maybe you can tell
tell us a bit about the improved bond
i mean we haven't really thought about
differential privacy for
you
switching that well one of the
um reasons we've
avoided it seems to be that well first
off it's not really clear how to apply
differential privacy for client to begin
with and second in general colorings
reveal a lot of random bits at once
so um
yeah
thanks
okay there's a question uh
uh by separate to a christian uh can you
see it or should they
that's all right that's all right um
uh so yeah this question is about the
multi-pass setting for set cover and
dominating sets so there are multi-pass
algorithms for set cover that work in
the set arrival setting that essentially
have np passes a dependency
uh that's roughly in and i think it's
rather into the one plus one over p
roughly and indeed uh yeah uh this works
out uh so you can get similar algorithms
also for the edge arrival settings so
you get exactly the same dependency and
it should be
met by um by the by the the existing
lower bound on the multi-pass
in a multi-part setting by by amit and
yeah by amit's paper
so since it
technology can be challenging so take
the uh take the time to write in the
chat if you have questions or or
or we can promote you
um
meanwhile one one question also to
christian about
about dominating sets um
does
do the approximation bounce become
better if for example we have a
guarantee about some upper bound
on the on the dominating uh
on the side of the dominating set
and
so that is scale
with the parameter
the interesting thing is i think the so
the
the uh the worst case seems to be indeed
when the dominating set size is constant
so the lower bounds all assume a
dominating set size of three or perhaps
even sometimes of size two and um yeah
so this doesn't help
i think you can indeed do the opposite
if you knew that the dominating set or
set cover is large in fact the optimal
set cover is large then your depends
space dependency can actually become
slightly better
uh but not the way round
uh so it's sort of the opposite
i guess what you would expect in that
sense
thank you
okay so there's another question in the
q a
and this is another question to to
christian
and this is about
whether you consider the problem in
random order streams
and whether the approximation factor can
be improved there
so uh yeah that's again that's a really
good question um
we
looked at this not necessarily for
dominating sets i'm not entirely sure
whether you can improve for dominating
set but if you look at the
generalization and you look at the sort
of edge arrival set cover setting and
you look at random order then indeed we
uh we can and have already obtained um a
slightly improved bound there was this
and my talk i mentioned that
um
we obtain a lower bound saying space
omega of m the number of sets is
necessary for achieving a root n
approximation
um in adversarial order and it seems
that the slower bound can be broken in
fact in the random order setting you get
a little of m space for root n
approximation for that so indeed is is a
very good question and the problem seems
to behave
differently in the random order setting
again um maybe another thing to others
that
in dominating set we essentially have n
sets in the universe of size n in set
cover we have m sets in the universe of
size n and um
in in a sense we have a trivial lower
bound of omega of n in general if we
wanted to sort of store a cover
certificate to say which sort of element
of the universe is covered by which set
now um
we also get a triple lower bound in the
set cover setting of omega of n even
though we have m sets
now this is a bit sort of the the
setting is a bit different because in
set cover and dominating set because we
have this different number of sets so
the n in the dominating set corresponds
to both the number of sets and the
universe size and instead cover it
doesn't so looking at it from a set
cover perspective is um is in a sense
um we get more insight into the problem
because these parameters are separated
and um sort of there's the dependency on
the sets and on the universe size and uh
yeah if um so
i think studying the problem from the
set cover perspective is more
interesting in fact or it provides more
insight into it
uh
so the next question is to anuhav
by separator
and this is
whether there is evidence
that there is no semi streaming
algorithm for one perception
approximation
in uh in polymer in employment time for
just a single pass
so
your result is in few processes the
question is about a single pass the same
result
uh yeah i don't i'm not aware if there's
any lower bound like that um
but um also i guess is this question for
tournament graphs or just like for a
feedback accent in general and i guess
like uh e for either of them like i i
don't know if there's like a if they're
just a little one like that
yeah uh for tournament graphs uh i'm i'm
not aware if there's a or like that
um
i i also have a question to anubhav
um
so uh so uh what you showed is i mean
you you basically use the local uh
improvement step of of adon
and they wonder whether these local
improvement steps also take a major role
in non-streaming algorithms in
uh yeah i think so
uh
uh i think in the context of like a
launch original paper like they used it
in a query efficient setting and uh even
in the original p-test like that's like
not a streaming algorithm and that also
uses uh these single vertex moves uh so
i think uh in general in like a lot of
literature of
uh the feedback archive problem like
single text moves are kind of like used
in different very different kinds of
settings
thank you
okay we'll
wait maybe one more minute for if there
are questions and if not uh
i guess we can uh we can end the session
so
um
okay so there doesn't seem to be they
don't seem to
i don't see any any questions until now
so
um so thanks again to to all the
speakers for uh for this
and the uh very nice results and very
nice talks
and uh see you
uh tomorrow
so
good evening good night to everyone
depending on or maybe good day for those
all right thank you bye
thanks
bye